[Musique]
marius narciso bonjour vous avez 56 ans
vous êtes membre du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais mais en
2014 lors de la première votre lors de
votre première présentation vous étiez
membre de la fédération socialiste de la
martinique
vous avez aussi utile premier adjoint du
maire sortant de ducos qui ne se
représente pas charles entre immense et
de 2001 à 2013 coûts en 2013 et pour
vous allez mener la liste en nous
semblait pouvant c'est bonjour marius
narciso bonjour le niveau i bonjour
aussi à tous les auditeurs de martinique
1ère et séculière man ou aux auditeurs
de ducos et puis permettez moi aussi de
sa présence à l'antenne pour souhaiter
une bonne et aux années 2020 à toutes
les martiniquaises il ya tous les
martiniquais
pourquoi vous présentez qu'est ce qui
vous motive écoutez c'est la continuité
de travail travailler comme ça vous
venez de dire que j'ai été le premier
adjoint de 2001 2013
aucun travail qui a été fait et
aujourd'hui la situation de la ville
fait que bombay nous nous devons tous du
côté nous nous de vous sentir concernés
par ces élections de façon à poursuivre
un travail qui a été fait et puis
surtout cherché à aller plus loin
donc c'est ça l'un des éléments forts de
la motivation
un bon jeu je lui dit vous êtes donc
investi par le mime est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une pression supplémentaire sur vos
épaules
le vouloir ramener coûte que coûte la
victoire à ducos un symbole parce que
face à vous vous avez entre autres
d'autres camarades d'anciens camarades
du mime je parle entre de dorine et là
est ce qu'il ya une pression
supplémentaire aucune pression aucune
pression parce que ce n'est pas déjà en
milliards pas de pression alfred
marie-jeanne 2002 pression sur qui que
ce soit chez nous c'est la démocratie
nous sommes là pour faire un travail
pour la martinique et puis la deuxième
chose c'est que leur ville qui a pas de
pression c'est pas une élection
politique c'est une élection municipale
c'est une élection où les gens de la
cité se mobilisent pour gérer la cité
vient quand même un enjeu face à vous
danse et mime venions jeu s'est pas
d'abord ramener la victoire et ne pas
2,9 surtout pas perdre face à aurélie
n'est là non nous ne sommes pas
personnellement je ne suis pas dans ce
genre de configuration
je suis de la quantité de travail que
j'ai commencé vous l'avait dit et c'est
très important parce que ducasse a
besoin on vous dit d'être remis sur les
rails de chercher à retrouver sa
splendeur d'antan et je considère qu'il
y ait un travail qui est fait au fait
qu'ils aient fait oui mais qui doit être
poursuivi que doit améliorer et la
vision que nous avons le projet que nous
avons s'appuie sur une vision qui est
très clair c'est le mieux vivre ensemble
à ducos alors mieux vivre ensemble du
cas ça passe pas quoi quels sont les
greniers de votre programme
je vous dis que cette ce programme
repose sur cette vision et cette vision
le mieux vivre ensemble à ducos
s'articule autour de quatre notions clés
et qui sont incontournables à mon sens
c'est d'abord jeudi la ville
la vue qui est ce territoire physique ou
le mieux-vivre physique doit s'exprimer
dans ça il faut que nous cherchons à
développer la tranquillité
l'attractivité et puis à l'intérieur de
la ville vous avez le quartier le
quartier par définition la déclinaison
de proximité puis le lieu d'identité et
à l'intérieur du quartier bien la
méthode pour y accéder c'est
l'intergénération à dire la petite
enfance la jeunesse les adultes les
seniors et puis pour sa baie pour
toucher l intergénération
nous avons un travail à faire sur un
souk et la famille la famille parce que
nous considérons qu'il faut favoriser la
promotion de la cellule familiale
il faut encourager justement la présence
des parents et pour cela et bien pour
arriver à ça et bien il faut qu'il y ait
justement une économie citoyenne voilà
les cinq éléments clés parce que nous
considérons que le développement
économique doit financer le social en
aidant le projet est finalisé nous
disons qu'il faut aller vraiment dans
une logique de développement durable où
on doit trouver un équilibre entre
l'économique le social et
l'environnement une économie citoyenne
je vois très bien votre deux autres
programmes et la ville de ducos on le
sait a été épinglée par la chambre
régionale des comptes avec un déficit
très important avec des recommandations
comment vous mener tout ça alors c'est
pour ça que je dis que notre projet
s'articule of s appuie sur 7 sur cette
vision mais il y a une priorité
c'est justement la situation
préoccupante que dresse la chambre
régionale des comptes et la chambre on
dit quoi
il ya deux choses a dit que nous avons
une situation qui fait que le déficit le
problème de déficit du fonctionnement de
la ville de khost pose problème
aujourd'hui c'est 7 millions de déficit
de fonctionnement là au 31 décembre 2019
l'année prochaine c'est 8 millions de
déficit qui sont prévues et en 2021 ses
9 millions 5 9 milliards de déficits qui
sont prévues dont vous prenez très bien
qu' on ne peut pas encore parler de
projet on peut pas parler
d'investissement moi je ne parle pas de
rêve la réalité c'est quoi et c'est ça
la priorité c'est que nous allons devoir
rétablir cette situation financière il
faut remettre la commune en équilibre et
j'attire l'attention sur une chose c'est
que quelle que soit l'équipe qui
arrivera après le premier tout une fois
que le sait qu on sera donné le 29 mars
cette commune aura un mois pour voter le
budget primitif
marius narciso je vous remercie
[Musique]